Hello, my name is Edward Bennet and I'm an instructor here at Epic Games.
Welcome to Introduction to Blueprints for Unreal Engine 5.3.
This course is a great starting-off point if you haven't done much programming before
and you are not used to using the engine.
At the end of this, we hope to give you all of the foundations that will allow you to
go on and become a more advanced programmer within the Blueprint system.
Our goals from this is to familiarize you with all of the terminology and programming
concepts that you're going to need to get started.
We're not going to go too deep, we're going to give you enough to be moving on with.
And then we want you to have a good understanding of how Blueprints fit into Unreal Engine,
where they can be found and how they can be used.
Lastly, we'll do an exercise.
And if you follow along with this exercise, you should get a good foundation on how to
create and write your own scripts within the engine.
Then you'll understand all of the different buttons and all of the different sections of the interface.
This should act as a good foundation to future learning.